near the start of the new millennium
American actor Jim Caviezel was one of
the hottest heartthrobs in Hollywood
with starring roles in the thin red line
frequency The Count of Monte Cristo and
more Caviezel seemed primed for a long
successful Hollywood career however
after taking on the career-defining role
of Jesus Christ in Mel Gibson's
controversial biblical drama The Passion
of the Christ Cavazos big-screen career
has been largely non-existent so what
happened
Hollywood reject according to Caviezel
accepting the title role in The Passion
of the Christ all but ensured the death
of his Hollywood career in fact only
minutes after Mel Gibson offered him the
role of biblical proportions the
director tried to talk him out of it as
Caviezel told one church congregation he
said you'll never work in this town
again
I told him we all have to embrace our
crosses but Caviezel claimed to care
little for Hollywood Awards accolades or
the Walk of Fame and was willing to
sacrifice his career for an opportunity
in Gibson's interpretation of the story
of Jesus explaining Jesus is as
controversial now as he's ever been not
much has changed in 2,000 years we have
to give up our names our reputations our
lives to speak the truth of course there
have been others who portrayed the holy
character on-screen and continued to
have fruitful careers so clearly there's
more to the story than that back to
school after playing Jesus Caviezel
decided to enroll in Spanish courses at
the University of Notre Dame he told the
school's Office of Public Affairs and
communications I'm in the process of
finally getting my college degree it's
like home here like family Notre Dame
was a no-brainer
I plan to be studying here when I'm not
working Caviezel didn't just study at
Notre Dame he also addressed students in
the grotto where he called on them to
have the courage to step into this pagan
world and shamelessly express your faith
in public he also attended football
games and participated in some student
section crowd push-ups so it wasn't all
business at least love scenes lost even
though romance certainly sells
especially in Hollywood Caviezel zhun
willingness to film love scenes makes
him an unattractive bid for pretty much
any movie aimed at adults Caviezel told
the New York Post in 2002 I have a hard
time getting naked on film I don't
believe in it I don't think it's right
in my faith
I'm taught that abstinence is important
you're never gonna see my butt on film
unless I'm in the Holocaust walking
around Caviezel did film
love scene with Jennifer Lopez in 2001's
romantic drama angel eyes but he made it
clear from the get-go that he wouldn't
be stripping down for the scene he
revealed I just said look put a top on
her
I'm gonna keep my shorts on she's gonna
keep her is on get the camera and shoot
around it and that's out of devotion
love and respect to my wife something
similar happened on the set of The Count
of Monte Cristo Polish American actress
tag Merida mens exceda
Tim took me aside and said you know I'm
married and very faithful I said Jim
it's a Disney movie I'm not gonna grab
your crotch such a conservative approach
to on-screen intimacy can have a
negative impact on building cast
chemistry workplace and worship in 2006
Caviezel appeared in a controversial
anti stem cell research commercial and
kicked off the advertisement by using
aramaic words to describe Judas's
betrayal of christ in the shack scholars
of the ancient language agree that using
the phrase effectively likens anyone
supporting stem-cell research to the
biblical trader himself he's also been
openly supportive of strongly
conservative politicians and refuses to
try and separate its faith from his
profession as he told the Polish press
in 2017
people in Hollywood keep asking me why
can't I separate my acting career from
being a Catholic my faith helps me to
make the right choices
the good news is he's had plenty of
opportunities to pursue religion
oriented work including narrating a 2016
documentary about pope john paul ii and
lining up to play saint luke in the
upcoming biblical drama film paul
apostle of christ career resurrection
Caviezel 'he's most notable post passion
role was that of former CIA agent John
Reese in the sci-fi crime drama Person
of Interest
which ran for five seasons on CBS the
show received generally positive reviews
and ratings during its run since the
2016 series finale which hit a ratings
low for the show Caviezel has yet to be
seen again on the small screen but he
may be heading back to where it all
began and ended by starring in Mel
Gibson's follow-up to the Passion of the
Christ he said of his return I won't
tell you how he's going to go about it
but I'll tell you this much the film
Gibson's going to do is going to be the
biggest film in history it's that good
considering both he and Mel Gibson have
had to work their ways back into the
mainstream for different reasons
their reunion should prove to be
interesting indeed thanks for watching
click the looper
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]